yesterday it was reported that there was
a massive 600 million dollar hack in the
crypto space this is absolutely
ridiculous now here's what occurred
ronin which is a bridge that is
connected to the axi infinity game had a
security breach and they tweeted it out
when we started actually go ahead and
take a look at what the hell occurred we
can see that that bridge which is simply
software that lets people convert tokens
into tokens that can be used on another
network there was a 173 600 ether and
25.5 million usdc tokens that were
extracted in two separate transactions
600 million dollars is a hell of a lot
of money especially when you look at the
fact that somebody in just two simple
transactions on a blockchain can take
that out of what many people thought was
a trusted secure piece of software now
of course if we go ahead and we take a
look we've got a quote here from the
folks over at elliptic they said in this
case the issue was that the bridge was
highly centralized the theft came as a
result of someone hacking the validator
nodes of the ronin bridge funds can be
moved out of the bridge if five of the
nine validators approve it the hacker
managed to get hold of the private
cryptographic keys belonging to five of
the validators so that was enough to
steal the crypto assets now of course
this is exactly how it works there
wasn't some crazy technical advantage
that they got they simply just got
access to the five keys that they needed
and if it's not your keys they're not
your coins and the bad actor the
nefarious person here they ended up
getting control of the keys if you have
control of the keys then you've got
access to the crypto and that's exactly
what they did here they went ahead and
they stole all of those cryptocurrency
assets now if we go ahead and we take a
look at this hack compared to others we
can see that there's only one other hack
the poly network that was bigger than
what we saw yesterday this is more than
what we saw in the mount gox or the
wormhole or the coot coin and many other
hacks that have occurred 600 million
dollars is a hell of a lot of money but
this is an overall trend we're not just
seeing really really big one-off hacks
we're also seeing lots of these occur
it's creating this long-term trend if we
look at this chart here chain analysis
tweeting out that the heck of the ronin
network is the latest in a series of d5
thefts in 2021 3.2 billion dollars in
crypto was stolen from individuals and
services that was 6x the amount that was
stolen in 2020 and so when you start to
actually look at how significant this is
it reminds everyone take the security
practices seriously unfortunately this
occurred there's a lot of people who got
hurt i'm hoping that the ronin network
can figure out how to go ahead and
correct this and that they can recover
some of the funds through a various set
of different means nobody likes that
there's criminal activity or there's
theft or bad actors in the space and
because it's done on a public blockchain
the odds are increased that actually law
enforcement will be able to identify who
these people are and hold them
accountable for their actions but at the
end of the day you as a user it is your
personal responsibility you have
sovereignty of your assets make sure
that you have your keys so that you have
your coins not your keys not your coins
that is one of the greatest lessons of
the 21st century hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time